[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are exploring the
question how do you balance living in
the moment versus documenting the moment
taking pictures man taking pictures I'm
this is a question from from Ashley at
fancy McGriddle thank you for the
submission Ashley on a weekend camping
trip I took no pictures this is her
talking at me I'm reading her a question
at this point totally I follow here I
think most people also do I was it was
nice to be away from my phone but I'm
sad I don't have any photo memories to
look back at how do I decide yeah it is
extreme not to take any photos on a trip
how do I decide if it's better to snap
photos versus live-in-the-moment phone
free hashtag air biscuits we're gonna
dig in on this question this is this is
the question we're gonna explore I think
there's an element of memory and
memories relationship to photos but then
you know once you talk about photos you
start talking about the gram and then
you start talking about I mean all of
these there's a lot of tension between
living in the moment and taking these
photographs that people have been taken
and then what do you do with them I I
didn't know it but I had slowly
developed some philosophy and you know
as we as we lead into Thanksgiving or if
you're watching the video version just
basking in the aftermath of that you can
it you can find yourself with lots of
photos or none or somewhere in the
middle so I photos tend to happen more
around the holidays so it's how
good-looking your family is it's nice
it's nice that we that we got a that we
wrap our minds around some people have
members of the family that don't want to
be in pictures oh gosh well we gotta get
okay I'll get into that too based on my
my my family speaking of Thanksgiving
there's a big Black Friday sale lasting
through Sunday at mythical calm
we got mythical merch up to 40% off so
when you're thinking about getting stuff
for yourself or other people for the
holidays and taking advantage of those
sales don't forget about mythical calm
yeah speaking of back in black I want to
tell you this a little something and ask
you a question okay before we get into
the question we live in a place where
there are black widows that's right and
it is not uncommon to find a black widow
and in fact I'd find it back in North
Carolina too but I have I think I found
more out here around my house so I've
found I don't think I ever saw one in
North Carolina well I probably I
probably did existed but I've seen them
it's like if you tell me hey boy find me
a Black Widow like if you come to my
house and you say that no one's ever
done that but if somebody did do that
like if the black widow collector Oh
came the Grim Reaper blasted OH
seven minutes I could have one seven
minutes I could have one in a jar I know
where one is in my backyard - all right
so in like 30 seconds I could have them
because I know where one is okay well
this is well we are definitely going to
get into it a second because you know
where one is and he's still there yeah
yeah okay so and also there's brown
widows which apparently are even you
know I'm out of brown recluse no there's
different there's a Bret there's a I
think it's a brown widow
isn't there a brown widow I don't know
well maybe I've got bad information but
somebody told me about a brown widow
kikyo's looking this up because in my
old house that I moved from there are
there's there was a bunch of brown
widows at least that's what in and Kieko
just confirmed they do exist
they still have a red hourglass on their
abdomen from what I remember yes it's
basically like a black widow but it's
brown and I think that it's not as
poisonous but there's more of them and
it's like it hurts even less but then it
hurts anyway I found one two nights ago
just out there it was and so Shepard has
found this while hiking last year he
found this stick that looks like one of
the walking sticks that if you ever go
into like one of those shops at like a
national park and if they're selling
like walking sticks like a gift shop
yeah like that has a nice walking stick
I'm thinking about getting one but you
never actually get one because what am I
gonna do with this walking stick I don't
need it to walk I think if I'm gonna do
that I'm just gonna go full ski poles
you know the people who are like really
getting hot on the hike in I've seen the
skis they got like through the walking
they look like ski poles and there's two
of them yeah this is Gandalf situation
this is like a staff I think you need
what I think if you if you think you
need one you really need to I think
actually having one makes it worse than
having none yeah you get asymmetrical
asymmetrical leg syndrome
anyway right at the bottom of he had his
staff kind of out calling his staff now
oh he bought one no he found one on a
hike okay and it is incredible it's way
taller than him it's big enough for me
it's probably almost six feet tall and
it is a perfectly straight thing and
I've actually talked to him about how we
need to like sand it down and like get
it lacquered shellac so then we could
like take it to a National Park store
and sell it for $25 so you'd be like one
of those guys out front
billy says don't buy the walking sticks
inside yeah I got you my son found this
one
I got you stick right over here but in
the meantime while we're waiting to
shellac it it is just leaning against
the house and between the staff and the
house there was a web and in the middle
of that web there was a giant black
widow so I have you say giant how do I
mean are you talking as big as they get
you know so a fat one oh gosh dang cover
your eye and eyebrow so I did what I
always do
right now first of all on I understand
spiders are goods don't give me that
okay I know spiders catch other insects
etc etc they're part of the ecosystem
but I don't want a black widow attached
to something that much
is going to grab and in and it's one
thing to see black widows like in a
garden area like kind of around your
house it's another thing to see them
attached to your house because that's
what this one was attached to something
that's made to be touched and I think
that once the black widow has made
contact with my domicile its rights have
ended and then subsequently its life
will end I'm not mr. put it in a jar and
no this is a spider what I do is I go I
grab spider killer spray that's what I
got not a sponsor
you got spider here's my regular spray
it got it on Amazon it comes in an
orange spray thing can and of course I
want this do you already own this spray
I've had it free I've had it ever since
I saw those first black widows and brown
widows around my house the last one
honey some of it I mean I got wasp and
Hornet spray but I never got the spiders
will laugh in the face you the spiders
will drink the Hornet spray like it's
Lacroix no impact no effect you got to
get spider killer spiders drink Lacroix
the ones I do once around my house -
yeah they're in California poor spiders
don't have a husband anymore out there
just getting thirsty so I said Shepherd
come here boy I got a lesson I'm sure he
comes running when you say you got
Alessia and so uh I'd say you didn't say
that no I just said Shepherd come here I
found a black widow oh and he was like
whoo cuz earlier in your testimony you
said Shepherd come here I got a lesson I
got a lesson now we're embodying I was
all lying that and so it was already
dark and we shined the phone light on
this black widow
I took the spider spray and I just
sprayed it directly on her her yeah so
if they look like a black widow are they
all females is there like a blessing Lee
there's a black widow that's like the
widower and Heath looks different mmhmm
yeah okay he's brown and so I sprayed
her and she reacted she's not happy this
was not look Roy
this is not Hornet spray what'd she do
she began to go up her web I'm feeling
sorry for this cuz this is exactly what
I wanted to get at okay she's lost as
she's gone she's going down this spider
is going up its web clearly impacted by
its spider spray the spider killer spray
okay me and my little boy are watching
it happen kind of enjoying it it's going
up this thing is getting slower and
slower and slower until I go it probably
went like six or seven feet oh that's a
big way up to the top of this thing that
was on the house and eventually it just
sort of just stopped and sort of curl a
little bit and that was the moment of
death time of death approximately 7:30 2
p.m.
stop drop shot him down open up shop oh
now we live in a world where a not
insignificant percentage of you
listening will be upset with me because
I killed a spider and watched it die
slowly and I can tell you're open to
hearing there and every your pre-emptive
disgust you can't even hear from a man
so all right what before I continuing
that Alan body I'm okay before I feel
bad man you lose your husband you get
sprayed rained on you and you realize it
was poison why did you have a spider
that you're not that you're listed
letting be you tell my Mary Mary quite
contrary named her she's she though and
she's not stuck to anything that
anyone's gonna grab because she's
underneath this the counter that's on
the back of my house you know the the
yard counter that I have the counter
where you like put out food when you
have me and my family over yeah but you
know despite it underneath it and way
down there and I coming over and I'm
bringing the spider killer and I'm gonna
bring my son and we're gonna film it
well I I was afraid that Jade was gonna
get up there and I'll kill your dog so
to be honest I didn't name this spider
and I intend to kill the spider
but I was afraid because I didn't have
anything and it was kind of it was you
have to say I have to squat down and
then there's like a electrical box and
then a little 3-inch gap and then
there's the the wall and she's in she
was dangling in that three inch gap so I
was like I'm gonna go get a broom and
I'm gonna I'm gonna jam that spider to
death
jam it but I didn't know spider spray
existed so I was gonna jail it to death
but I knew that the chances of it
running away
we're very high that this is a thing and
the spider spray yeah okay but you got a
broom I didn't I and then when I was I
don't want that to happen when I was
already did what happened when I was
walking to the broom I got it's a long
ways to my broom by the time I got in
the room I didn't know why I was going
for the broom I'd forgotten and then I
remembered a couple of times including
right now that I never did anything
about Mary you know cuz Mary is having
babies that's what she goes a little egg
sack full of little poisonous black
widows that can infect your dog and your
children I need you to come over with
that spider spray okay because I'm not
gonna buy I don't like having that stuff
around I don't I don't believe in it I
think it's violent I think it's I think
it's wrong so I'm not gonna own it but
I'd like for you to bring some over and
kill this the reason I have no guilt
associated with this is because that
spider does not have the nervous system
capable of contextualizing suffering and
therefore doesn't have the ability to
experience suffering in the way that you
do and you then project onto a spider
because you've seen movies like
Charlotte's Web where the spider can
talk
well that spider once motivated and that
spider was voiced by a person and it was
a story written not by a spider but by a
person okay
EB white exactly you know EB White's a
freaking spider no it's a person EB
White Widow so yeah and I just think
that there's something intrinsically
okay with the human instinct to
eliminate a threat especially a tiny
little threat that packs such a punch
well and I don't think there's anything
wrong with watching it die let's not
undersell the threat
but let's unpack it a little bit one
time I think I recently told you this
story but I don't think I told it to
anyone else so now I will tell it how
are you I remember and you tell me if I
told you yes I remember one time I was
sitting in my my nanny's yard with my
nanny because my nanny would often take
her chairs out into the yard and we
would just sit in the yard sitting in a
yard was something that used to happen
it doesn't happen anymore
you should happen again people should
sit in their yards like there was a big
pecan tree and we sit underneath it and
just just sit yeah and talk let begins
drop into your mouth like raindrops like
like like grapes being fed to a king
right one time I struck up a
conversation with nanny because what
else are we gonna do we're sitting under
a tree I said nanny tell me some of the
some of the last words that your
relatives said before they died I
remember asking how old were you I was
pretty young I was probably like Lando's
age like nine ish because I distinctly
remember it and I was in quitter but
thought I just thought it'd be a fun
thing where she related to inner spiders
it was interesting that like she
actually remembered a number of family
members last words but the only one that
I distinctly remember is one that
weren't wasn't words at all because she
said and of course my great-uncle
so-and-so so-and-so he died on the
toilet well it was actually an outhouse
he got bit on the butt by a black widow
spider mm-hmm and it killed him you
would think you would be especially
prone to killing black widows because in
like me too like a venture from
great-great uncle I never I never met
him and I don't even know his last words
were there what oh I think I just got
bit by spider his blood runs in your
veins that's true
well the blood of his like father I
guess does he's your uncle yeah
somewhere up there the blood and his
butt runs through my veins right and
that but that was bitten by a black
widow that now it's just sitting there
enjoying the fruits of
your backyard how does a black widow
kill a human with the venom like first
of all I don't I don't know that it is
that even true a my nanny lying to me I
think it's unlikely that you died from a
black widow bite but it definitely
guarantees a pretty bad weekend mmm what
do you find it near signs and symptoms a
black widow spider bite muscle cramps
and spasms that start near the baikman
spread and increase in severity in 6 to
12 hours chills fever nausea vomiting
sweating severe belly back or chest pain
headaches stupor restlessness or shock
spider how long does it take to a black
widow bite to kill you if a black widow
spider bites a person do not panic no
one in the United States has died from a
black widow spider bite in over 10 years
yeah but my great great uncle back in
the outhouse days famous he's famous for
that his fingers are dying very often
the Black Widow will not inject any
venom into the bike no serious symptoms
develop wash the wound well with soap
and water to help prevent infection so
I'm kind of getting this thing about
that in there about before it bites you
kill it with the spider spray because
that's what I would add to the wiki hell
I'm sorry I know I was a spider bite is
said to feel like a pinprick all the
victims may not realize they have been
bitten most common localized Simms in a
black widow spider include immediate
pain burning swelling and redness around
the bite basically it seems that it's
it's al it's not even that painful not
even that much of a threat so that's a
wrap maybe we just let me let them
dangle III understand the argument that
we're encroaching on their ecosystem I
mean you can if you stretch that
argument to its logical and though I'm
also an animal and I decided to live
here so but anyway I'm not talking about
eliminating all spiders I understand
they're an important part of the local
ecosystem but the spiders that have
gotten the bright idea to attach to my
house that's where it is I'm not talking
about going out into the world and
seeking out black widows like some so
a superhero that just he's called
spider-man but he's just a guy who kills
spiders and he has a copyright problem
like there's a trademark issue because
every time he tries to make a movie
about himself or whatever people get
confused and they think it's the Marvel
spider-man and he's like no I'm just the
guy who kills spiders
maybe I should be called the spider guy
but that doesn't sound like a great
superhero I'm not advocating for that
potential thing I'm just saying I'm
gonna kill him if they if they threaten
me
here's another family here's another
fact black widow spider bites rarely
kill people but especially for kids it's
important to get medical attention as
soon as you can because they can make
you very sick like the symptoms that are
no I don't want my kids to be very sick
well hook me up with that spray I'm
gonna go for it okay alright see I'm
convert I'm a closeted convert oh no and
say that publicly okay let's get let's
get into something a little less morbid
but first we do invite you to visit
mythical calm where you can get all the
spider spray up I'm getting word that we
do not sell spider spray you know we
don't you're lying now if you're
watching this on the day that it comes
out then it's the Sunday after
Thanksgiving and that means that you
just got a few more hours to take
advantage of our Black Friday sale
mythical calm you get over get up to 40%
off so make sure you take advantage of
that or you could just start wearing
plain white t-shirts like I'm doing
they're cheap they don't say anything
about you I have one of those and I put
it on yesterday I walked around in front
of a mirror and I was like you know what
and I took it back off sometimes I go
for it yeah just didn't express enough
you know what I'm the expression okay
mythical calm you be the expression all
right so I'm gonna I'm gonna reiterate
this question and then we can dive into
it again Ashley said on a weekend
camping trip I took no pictures it was
nice to be away from my phone but I'm
sad I don't have any photo memories to
look back at how do I decide if it's
better to snap photos
versus live-in-the-moment phone-free
well I'm actually tomorrow as we're
recording this I'm leaving to take my
youngest son on a camping trip returning
to Joshua Tree oh I wanted to take both
of the children but the oldest child
didn't want to be with you know he has
basketball practice on Saturdays and the
coach is pitching a fit about not
missing any how many other days a week
tis the upright five it's to the sixth
total I mean the way they do the high
school sports now is just come on guys
like it's not there it's not the only
thing that matters like being able to go
do something on the weekend with your
parents I don't understand why that
there's no value in that I don't know
it's a little frustrating but I wanna oh
he's committed to it so I want to honor
that commitment it actually makes me mad
I know it makes me mad for you guys I
don't know it's just it doesn't seem
like really you want I mean it doesn't
really boil down to you want to win so
badly that you're drunk you know you're
you're driving these kids to practice
six out of seven days a week I think
there's just a mentality about what that
commitment yeah it's not unhealthy
but leads to things that given the
lifestyle that we live and the way we
want our family to be it becomes a bit
of it clashes like the fact that we
didn't go we did holding your family
hostage we didn't go home to North
Carolina for Thanksgiving or Christmas
last year because they were told if you
miss the game the tournament's that we
play over the holidays you will then be
demoted a team that just don't agree
with it I don't agree what about this
year are you not going on for this year
we're going home for Christmas and we're
just saying but you couldn't do
Thanksgiving well this year for the same
reason well we decided we're gonna do
for Christmas because it's gonna be a
longer period of time and we didn't go
back last year but we're he's biting the
bullet this year because it's just like
I mean I'm how much longer am I going to
be able
be in this family where as a family we
go back to our visit right I don't know
that's not really what I wanted to get
it okay I'm sorry you just kind of we
could do a whole nest about the issues I
have with the policy of the local high
school basketball team a coach setting
up a standard that then immediately and
fringes on like you're you're the whole
family's ability to plan anything just
seem to just I don't know it just makes
me angry well I I'm on board with that
that's why I don't let my kids play
sports
so me and Shepherd are going me and
Shepherd are going and you know
interestingly last time we went to
Joshua Tree the three of us cuz like it
was not during basketball season we one
of the things that I remember most about
that trip was the pictures do you mean
you remember the trip as to the extent
that you do because you took pictures
which you've seen since then the way
back into that memory is often easiest
in the form of revisiting the pictures
which I also put on Instagram because I
thought that I took some really good
pictures and I thought that's the
different I thought that you would be
shout out to read em see on Instagram I
thought you would be impressed with my
photo taking ability I what I what I was
really trying to communicate back to Dan
what I wanted you to think that I think
that you would think was that I was just
a good father but what I really wanted
you to think was that he's a really good
photographer he's a great father and a
great photographer he's a photographer I
didn't come out right
so I guess to bring it full circle if if
I get my way then the coach won't insist
that you can't take your kids places so
then you can boost your Instagram cred
like yeah you know I'm no I'm fighting
for you over here no it was a it was
great it was a great trip I'm just
saying that this pictures were a great
way back into it but the it I'm at a
table the Instagram thing for a second
because that's it that's another facet
to this argument but my first question
is
are your memories of your previous
Joshua Tree trip directly associated
with things in the photos or is it just
that it jogs your memory about other
things that you didn't take photos of
I'm actually curious if all of the above
you lose all of the above for instance
because at a certain point I took a
picture of Shephard and Locke I don't
believe that this one I think there is
one of these it doesn't matter you can
show it no but I'm saying that they're
trying to promote you no no no I'm not
no I'm what I'm using his Instagram as
I'm saying I'm actually more likely to
see the pictures that I posted to
Instagram rather than the pictures that
are on my camera roll because my camera
roll has so many pictures yeah so I've
looked at my old Instagram feed more
than I go back and look at all the
pictures from Joshua Tree but one of the
pictures was I think either me or
Shepherd or Locke it's on a giant rock
meditating and we hike to the spot and
me and Shepherd will do this again
because it was one of my favorite spots
all of Joshua Tree has this giant
awesome house size rocks that you can
just so easily climb on top of but we
climbed on three rocks and we were
probably like 50 to 75 yards apart from
each other in a triangle and we were all
meditating and I took pictures of us
each and just the picture of one of us
on that rock takes me back to that
really special memory which I remember
in its entirety or at least as much as
has been retained there's like that was
just a really cool moment like we
literally just sat there in silence
taking in nature for you know ten
minutes or so I think that in a lot of
situations though at a certain point you
only remember the things that you well
we know you only remember the things
that you could that you that you have
remembered like remembering shapes the
memory accessing it so that accessing
over ice and you're most likely to
remember the things that you've taken
photos of the things that are just
related to it you might lose earlier
because there's nothing that's going to
prop that specifically at least in
theory so
that's an argument for taking more
pictures right but there's also an
argument for taking none like she seemed
to imply that she didn't bring her phone
at all and you know we want to applaud
that because it's to be away from your
phone has got to be it that's got to be
rejuvenating on some without a brain and
physical level how about this is so
getting rid of the phone entirely was
probably a good thing she just happened
to get rid of her camera at the same
time because it was in the phone well
how about this situation specifically
because I think that this is maybe a
little bit a more specific scenario
where I have a stronger opinion where it
just seems clear in my mind I like to
watch professional golf on television
the most boring thing that you can
choose to do I understand it doesn't
appeal to everyone I'm immediately
picturing you taking pictures of the
screen as you're watching golf because I
don't know where you're going with this
and if you watch a golf
gallery which is the audience watching
who's following around the players if
you go back to 19 if you go back to the
year 2000 definitely and you look at
pictures of like Tiger Woods getting
ready to putt or something and you look
at the gallery behind him everyone would
just be standing there looking at Tiger
Woods yeah if you go back to this year
and you see Tiger Woods putting at the
Masters or whatever you will see that
seven out of ten people have their phone
up some of those people are looking at
Tiger in real pers in real life but then
pointing their phone at him and some
people are literally just looking at
their image that they're gathering of
him in the moment now here's the deal
this seems asinine to me because you
know what else is happening while you're
filming Tiger Woods the freaking network
that is documenting him playing golf is
filming it much more clearly than you
are and also broadcasting
you can go back to that moment through
the wonder of network television at any
time you think you're gonna go back and
look at your little dinky little camera
vertically film camera and that you
Bueller does where I was well yeah I
definitely don't understand license
watch Tiger Woods play golf man I don't
understand taking video of things that
would you're at an event as a spectator
and like especially with something like
that where there's only key moments
there's like there's 18 times this guy's
driving you know off the tee it's one
thing to be like here comes Tiger and
analyst I went to the Wachovia I
remember what Cove via the bank yeah
they had a championship I don't know if
they still have it in Charlotte and my
dad and I positioned ourselves on the
tee right next to the tee box like we
were as close to like where the golfer
was gonna come up
Tiger Woods comes up it's a drive right
in front of us this was before anyone
was filming anything with phones so I
just watched it happen it was amazing
do you remember it yes I remember it
it's in my mind now it would have been
one thing that as as Tigers coming up
like pull up my phone and snap a little
picture of them and put it back it's the
people who are literally videoing
everything that's happening while it's
happening in front of them that that
makes me mad knowing that what yeah yeah
are you really gonna watch that back I'm
so that that's one end of this book
that's why a picture so great is that
it's a moment in time it's a it's a it's
a snapshot of reality quite literally
you know but it but then it's over
and you can be in the moment I again I
think if there's a if you have such an
attachment to your phone that you can't
really enjoy camping then I think you
should get rid of the phone but we may
be reaching a conclusion where you
should bring some other type of camera
which could be weird like what if you go
retro though that's kind of fun you're
going camping its rustic why don't you
take one of those disposable things and
just take that role and then develop it
and then take pictures of those
developed em and scan them so then you
cuz you got to have it digitally okay
that's one solutions like a cumbersome I
just came up with that it's like this
retro
Oh rustic photography thing I like that
idea that could be fun but that should
do that but I get disposable camera and
don't take your phone now that feels
like a potential cool sort of temporary
solution now we have to be kidding let
me just say I keep getting the sense
that we've talked about this before
either on your biscuits or something
else but you know what I'm gonna trudge
through if you know if we have it's a
good test because you remember it if we
take a picture if we took a picture of
it then that means that it didn't even
help us remember it right and this whole
conversation I know I've toyed with two
reasons well I've had it and we were
wrong about it but why can't why can't
two dudes talk about the same thing
again maybe their minds have changed
that is the other test have our minds
changed so I have a system but go ahead
well I want to come back to yours you
like this system I think this is fine
system but let me just quickly just for
the sake of understanding all the places
that this could go can we could just
fast-forward to the distant future maybe
they're not so just a future because you
could technically do this now but it
would be a cumbersome life of choice so
just like security systems house they're
recording constantly and it's and it's
just being held on a hard drive this
would be like let's just say in your
brain like you'd be able to access well
what you I think you fast forward it
even be you fast forward it's so far
into the into the distant future we're
now on the future so okay okay look you
know we're glass let's do both let's do
a nest cam on my glass that's exactly
what I'm getting it I'm saying you've
got a pair of glasses that are
fashionable they don't look like Google
glass they're like oh those are just
glasses like what link has on really
recording whatever is very in fashion
it's like a traffic cam and sending it
to a cloud-based abased server that then
is just like in first of all I know
there's a movie about this at least one
movie about this and I can't remember
it's called we have made we may have
made it and forgotten it but essentially
you can go back and you can access any
of your memory
from the perspective that you were in
the sound and the the audio of that at
that point everyone's basically just
gonna it's I don't know that's gonna be
a weird time if we get to that point and
with the evolution of technology but you
kind of fast-forward it beyond that
which is an even more interesting place
which is not only is it being stored on
the cloud based system but it's the
interface between your brain and the
cloud based system is so seamless that
going back into the memory feels like
just reliving the memory so every
sensation not just your the site in the
sound but also the feel and your
emotions and everything you could now
there's also a book I think was a wreck
in effect way back by Blake Crouch one
of my favorite writers recursion where
he plays around with this concept of
memory and being able to enter back into
a memory and basically the underlying
philosophy of the book is that we're the
only thing we really consists of is
memory right that's it like that's kind
of all that we've got is this timeline
that we've sort of recorded I don't
understand what about the the present
the nowness like you've got now well oh
and you've got an aspiration to the
future right but you've actually got a
lot of things yeah I know what I'm doing
I'm just throwing all that there's a
little there's just a lot to this
argument but I guess we can just zoom
back in on the present day because yeah
in the future in the future it will be a
moot point I think it but you won't be
making that decision I think if you
could have constant access to everything
that's happened to you in in pristine
probably POV vantage point I don't think
it will be healthy I don't think you'll
be healthy to have it I think it would
just it doesn't it seems like it would
work for like in court you know it's
like yeah but it's a very no but think
about it because these are just getting
wild because if we can get to a place
where the
the pass is not held the interface yep
oh no this isn't about living in the
past if the interface is seamless then
if I can have the experience of going to
Joshua Tree without even going to Joshua
Tree and I'm not talking about virtual
reality I'm talking about a literal the
experience is being piped into my brain
at that point photos it's just like we
just got to send one person to Joshua
Tree have them do everything with where
while wearing the interface and then if
I can have the exact same experience why
am I gonna get in the car and drive
yeah that's convenient but it I'm just
saying you proved my point that doesn't
that doesn't seem healthy either
specifically so in general I don't I
don't think we're ever gonna get to that
point I even with technology in the way
that is advancing I think there's just
too many limitations and okay but if we
reel it back to the day I I'll try to
make it simple because I think I think
I'm adopting a practice that is my
answer to this I've never articulated it
so as I try to do that let's see if it
holds up I think there's a balance
between you know this is kind of a
middle-of-the-road thing which may seem
obvious but there's a balance between
not taking any photos taken too many
photos so I think the the goal is to
know how to take just the right amount
of photos and I'll be more specific I
think if there's any moment and I
believe that I try to make my goal
especially when I've made plans to do
something that's event based it's like
well when I'm in it I really want to
appreciate it to be in that moment and
savor it for all that it is and then
I've noticed that if I do that if I
recall that intention and I and I start
to really appreciate the moment mm-hmm
that then if I add a little brain
trigger to that conclusion then I oh
yeah I am in the moment that like at
some point around here in time I'm gonna
snap a photo in order to help me
remember a moment when I was in the
moment now I don't want it's actually
almost a way to signify that this moment
is worth being in yeah but
not dropping what I'm doing in order to
get the perfect frame or something right
now but just saying I'm making a mental
note that like at the right time maybe
when the height of this moment has
passed I will snap a picture to
commemorate it or if I can snap a photo
and then still and put my phone back
away and still be in the moment I'm
gonna do that as opposed to making the
moment trying to capture the moment
which incidentally I'm sure you've seen
this but if you live in Los Angeles and
you go to any place you will see there's
usually a couple and it's usually I this
is a this is a this is definitely a
generalization so let me just say in my
experience 8 out of 10 times there is a
woman who is on the attractive side and
she is doing something and her boyfriend
her husband has a camera and is being
forced to sit there and take a hundred
pictures of her doing something no no no
her Instagram he forces her she forces
him to take a photo or five then she
comes and looks at him give notes and
then she goes back to where she was it
happens five more times and this is okay
I think we are both in agreement that
this is way out way out of bounds this
is I understand that maybe instagramming
is your career but what I good luck but
that doesn't apply yeah if your is like
that is now autolearn its degree is
outside of the realm of being in the
moment because the moment has become
about you getting the moment now for
yourself before I accolades admiration
that you're gonna get on Instagram now
sometimes I don't know that you did this
but if you're doing this meditation on
the rocks and it's like wow this is an
amazing moment i'ma put the way that I'm
saying you would do that is you would
just pull out a phone I'd look out a
corner my I'd see my son over there on a
meditation rock I pull out my phone I'd
I'd take a snapshot and then I put it
back away and I keep meditating it
wouldn't become like let me let me
figure out how to take the next 20
minutes to make this
moment that's exactly what I did there
were a couple of other moments where we
were hiking and we hiked into this cave
and then we realized that there was a
really cool opening into the sky and we
took I'd say we stopped and we took like
two minutes getting like Shepherd like
set up in this cave to like take this
picture but it wasn't this light
everything is stopping for an extended
period of time it was like oh this is a
cool photo op this is it let's capture
this moment in a stylistic way all that
to say the way that I did it last time I
do not feel like I ever made it about
the photos to the extent that I lost the
ability to be in the moment I feel like
I was in what I would say is my sweet
spot which is what I plan to do but I do
think that there are times when a
conscious choice to be like I'm not I
think any photos may be when it may be
when you're by yourself like I know we
both talked about potentially doing and
my therapist is like been pushing me to
do this for awhile to take a like take a
solo trip somewhere I've done a couple
of times or whatever but I feel like if
I were to do something that like that it
would there could have an extended
period of time where I'm not taking any
photo no I'm saying that everything
that's worth doing this worth
experiencing if you find yourself truly
experiencing it you're in a moment that
then you should find the right way to as
quickly as possible take a snapshot
which will help solidify it so it's not
just a you want to take a mental picture
but but what if you want to mitigate
lately but what if you for a I think
that's a here's what I'm thinking it's
so like I true whenever I'm doing
something like if I go camping I'm like
you know I want to take a picture that
like helps me remember this whole thing
and then I don't want to keep taking
pictures so I man once we set up camp
I'm gonna walk over here and I'm gonna
take a big picture of the campsite with
as many people as I'm camping with in it
you know I know I'm not I and that's
just for me if I look back to decide oh
yeah
I remember that campsite I remember this
whole weekend yeah and then if there's a
moment within that like oh we found this
waterfall or like we're sitting around
the campfire and we're having this
conversation I'm gonna pull out and I'm
gonna try to my phone and I'm gonna take
like one picture and then I'll be like
you know what I I got it I any of that
memory that might be lost from not
having a picture I've now mitigated that
risk and I can be back in the moment
then I put it away now I think try
adding the the factor of trying to put
it on the Internet it severely
complicates things for me personally
well don't but you don't make that
decision you don't make that decision
I'll do because it's the difference
between taking a photo to capture a
moment for you and capturing something
that looks good that people will like on
the Internet
I don't think that there's I don't think
that that's a super position I don't
think there's a huge delineation but
hosing I think for most people I this
might be because you're such a
perfectionist and if you're gonna take
something for the purpose of display you
get to in your head about it and take
too much time to make like that woman
who's making sure she gets she wants to
look exactly and she wants to look even
if you feel like you would be too I like
I honestly don't go to that place it's
just like I'm like okay I I want to take
a picture of this I might exactly the
right place to take the best picture of
that
probably not but I'm not gonna take the
time to figure that out it's just when I
frame it I'll think about the rule of
thirds and I'll take a visually you know
pleasing shot and then I'll go back when
I get back home and I'm like showing
Jesse like hey here's what we did here's
the pictures so she can kind of live
vicariously through what it was like to
go out she we don't let her know she
likes good to get weekends by herself
sometimes and so that's what happens and
then I will show those pictures and then
I'll pick the best ones and be like ah
this I'll do a little photo set and I
haven't done that very often I just did
it with Joshua Tree specifically last
year when we were in Thailand and we
were like touring those ancient ruins me
and my family I do remember thinking
like oh this is like
we got to get all the family here and
this tour guides gonna take our photo
and you know I noticed that the kids are
like ah stop that you try to get them
all posing and even though they're
always on their phones they can't stop
whatever they're doing to like perfectly
pose for my picture and I am thinking I
kind of have something that like I could
put as a fridge magnet like to send back
home to the extended family you know
these are the these are the trips that
lead to the fridge magnets and they're
also the pictures that lead to the next
trip right right because if you want to
yeah you know interestingly Jesse
recently did something but it's got to
be a good picture
Jesse's good at she's good at taking
pictures and she just uses her phone and
then a little bit of whatever the
editing stuff is and then she took she
went through a bunch of her pictures and
then printed out several of them and put
them in our the bathroom that we redid
and so like on the shelf that you can
see while you're taking a crap which I
really like to have a good field of view
and I'm taking a crap you're going on
vacation in your mind I see these cool
pictures that she's taken and she did
and it isn't like it doesn't have us in
them his pictures that she took of
things so it almost looked in the chitin
they're all black and white so it kind
of looks like oh you just bought a
picture
you bought a frame with a picture in it
but it's like I know people visiting my
bathroom they think oh they just have
like cool nature slash building slash
stock photography in this decorative
place but I know no I remember that
building that we went to in England and
that ruling or what yeah
and that that's very meaningful for me
especially while defecating it helps you
bags a lot I mean the experiences that
you had there and the meaning associated
with that it's a direct it helps you
access it that's why just putting the
phone away when you're like having to go
back to what you were saying there I
think that's the flip side of this coin
that I'm not happy with yet which is I
don't know if they're a healthy time
take any photos I do think I question oh
I think so
because okay let me just paint a picture
for you you're on a solo trip you you
you've set us out a couple of days to be
by yourself yeah and you are becoming so
one with nature that you begin to look
down and you see these these the
synthetic fabric on you're like what do
i why do i why do i have this this isn't
me you begin to strip your clothes off
trip are you on good question you you
strip your clothing off because you
realize that that's not you man that
aint it chief okay you are your body
can't call me chief I do like that and
you say I want to have I don't want to
be anything that wasn't here to begin
with I mean you even take your wedding
ring off I mean not because you're
looking to get frisky but because it's
it's it's foreign
you take your glasses off you can't see
anymore it doesn't matter every you you
grab a leaf and you rub under your arms
to get any remnants of deodorant off of
you because you want to be of nature
with nature and then you walk several
miles away from the campsite with no
regard as to what direction you're going
because you want to be in it to win it
you get out there you didn't bring your
phone let's just stuck out in a crevice
of sorts you there's a moment there's a
moment out there while you're naked and
you're one with nature where it's about
you and your brain and the cosmos and
it's not about capturing it with some
little dinky digital device that was
invented ten years ago right wrong but I
just took a picture of you because
you're so worked up I just feel like
that's the moment and I don't want to
forget and I agree with your philosophy
in general I'm just saying there are
times I think what you gotta set it all
aside I think what you're saying is that
if yours isn't there something ironic
about being in a moment so you're taking
your phone out and taking a picture of
it isn't that cow
in the moment sometimes the moment is so
great that it can't take the informality
of taking out a phone yeah like like the
moment that your first child being born
or the second of the third like what's
gonna happen what's gonna happen when
the aliens come I think we're talking
the birth thing is a good one better
than the aliens because the babies look
like aliens especially at first it's
it's the it's the filming of the whole
birth I mean that one's always just
bumfuzzled me because it's a gross birth
man I mean it's it's not even I mean it
is a beautiful thing but yeah but
physically it's an isn't it nasty kind
of thing but did you hear that it's like
why are you talking about filming that
or taking photos of that no take photo
of the result but hold on but GoPros be
free and free and post
GoPro came out with a vag cam though you
know GoPro GoPro nine then you just tell
the baby to follow the light right it's
just used you swallow the right the
doctor puts it okay yeah on and then you
see the whole thing that way
GoPro not a sponsor yeah they really
want to be now I think I think in theory
you could be right there a moment so
precious that bringing a camera phone a
phone camera or whatever it is into the
situation is gonna tame it but that's
not that is so more but that's that's
the moment of birth the moment of death
I'm go to death well I kind of wanted
the moment over probably the moment of I
mean don't get me started with sex tapes
well that's that'll get you in trouble
you know so let's take them off the
table
mmm-hmm you know again pre and a post
that's a different thing though pre
picture post picture again I said don't
get us started guess that it sounds like
you want to make it another episode okay
with possibly two sex tape or not to sex
tape that is the question okay maybe in
2020 with everything we're thinking
about 2020 you could be the year the
retin lake sex tape that is done
I don't get that would put us on the map
we're not will be able to sell more
makeup than Jeffrey star and Shane
Dawson I think for most all situations
that are on except for the exceptional
ones that I just listed I guess yeah be
ready to take what you think are too few
photos but not zero photos and I would
say while I agree with your philosophy I
think it is sound my approach is
probably a little bit less about just
capturing it for the sake of your own
memory and accessing the memory later it
is that but if you're gonna take the
time to take a photo take a nice photo
that could be shared with the world okay
but don't make that an addendum and as a
second point there's nothing wrong with
wanting to take some postable photos but
you just got to know that that's most
likely going to take a more time and
that's it's a trade-off between being in
the moment and being in this I'm
creating something that will become a
digital moment later so you just got to
know that the clock is ticking
whenever you decide I think this is the
one I'm on the edge of the Grand Canyon
my kids aren't that upset with me we're
gonna we're gonna get the tour guide to
be cooperative and taking nice composed
photo for me to put on my magnets and to
put on Instagram and but I know that my
clock is ticking and every time I do
that and every single precipice of the
Grand Canyon should not be us attempting
to outdo the last hundred percent on
instinct with your specific thing that
you just said and this might just be the
difference in the way that our brains
work you seem like you want to make the
decision before you snap the photo about
what where it's gonna go and what the
purpose of the photo is yeah and I'm
just saying I want to have a philosophy
of capturing moments as I go capturing
them and
and not unreasonably aesthetically
pleasing way but you know reasonably
pleasing and then later on when I get
back home in the privacy of my own bed
or bathroom I want to go through my
camera roll and make that decision I
don't want to make because if you have
to bring that thought process into the
moment
it ruins the moment well I I I don't
think there's one right answer I think
that the key is an hour difference of
what takes us out of a moment and what
keeps us from being able to get back in
a moment
I'm I yeah I think it is important to
say I'm highly sensitive it I'm like the
experienced version of a light sleeper
I'm I must be a light experiencer
because anything can knock me out of the
orbit of a moment right you know if you
think about like literally being in a
moment you think about like trying to to
meditate and if a fly buzzes and it
takes you all the way out of it and it
for me I grab chopsticks if a little fly
buzzes well it's not about being
superior now if your phone seems to say
that not only are we different but I'm
I'm I'm winning what I'm saying is mr.
Miyagi made it seem like it was a camera
trick but I can actually do it in person
so I needed to look at my son myself and
say okay I can get obsessive about
trying to take so many photos to get the
best one for the fridge magnet and at
the end of the day I could realize that
I was never you know really experiencing
it and so I need to I I need to set
ground rules for myself now you're sit
so those may be different for you
because of you know the what what puts
you in a moment the only thing I'm
asking because I think that this could
bring I'm not asking you to do my
technique I'm just saying that doesn't
your technique still work if you take
the moment of decision about Instagram
out of that moment and just save it for
later and just be like I'm just gonna so
do your thing so you're saying just take
a take a but then no no the application
is you
much more no no no you're not listening
what I'm saying take the exact amount of
photos that you were planning on taking
take the take them in exactly take the
exactly amount of time to take them and
to consider them that you're planning on
taking and then if when you get back
home see if anything qualifies it
doesn't work this morning I put into
practice what I'm talking how does that
not work and I'll tell you why I don't
work I got up I was drinking my coffee
it was early sitting there all alone no
one was stirring then all of a sudden
somebody was stirring so lando comes
around the corner wakes up it's like a
half hour earlier normally wakes up he
came and he sat down next to me on the
couch with his blanket and like so I was
drinking my coffee and he was like
snuggled up to me it was a nice moment
and he may have pulled out his he's got
this knitting loom and like he's so he's
he's he's knitting something or hand
it's like a is it knitting is that what
it's called let's just say this I'm not
I'm not familiar with it um he's making
something special for somebody and I was
like you know what this is a special
moment and I reached I just took out my
phone I didn't say anything to him and I
just took a selfie and you know it's not
a good looking selfie matter of fact I
don't want to show you the selfie now in
a normal year biscuit right now on the
video version we'd be showing the selfie
I'm not gonna do that because I haven't
even looked at it
I probably it's probably not a
flattering angle but and it's a moment
that meant something to me but like it's
like if I really thought that it in
order for that to be post worthy you
gotta I mean I would have taken 12 in
order to try to figure it out because
you just can't slam out a selfie and
it'd be amazing I mean yeah you seen
people they take forever to get the chin
and pointed in the right direction I
just don't think you're being honest no
with you just can't
there's never see snapping a shot to
preserve a moment and snapping a shot
that could mean something more like one
you know it's a lot more work for me I'm
saying that it's a it's a minimal amount
more work take me through but take me
through your fridge magnets or your
Instagram
feed and show me what which of those
were just taken on a fluke somebody's
singing no no I'm saying I'm having a
real eight explain it sounds like what
you want to do is it in again I get it's
your personality because it legitimately
listen I'm your best friend I've known
you for almost 40 years and I work with
you every single day I know how an
interruption to the flow of whatever is
happening disrupts gets you upset but
I'm just also saying my photos they're
not good enough to be pumped I dope what
I'm saying is that the extra 20 seconds
that I might take like if I if I if the
same exact thing happened to me
Shepard came out to me and began to knit
you're taking my photo here right now
this is a moment yes sir I might it
might be like this right so he would
come up he'd be next to me that would be
it so maybe I took seven seconds where
you took one second and what what if I'm
like hold on him I blinked in that one
I'm just I'm not eyes we're closed I'm
saying I'm not going to review it
because I don't I'm not taking it
because I want to post it I'm taking it
because I want it to become a candidate
for anything that I want to be able to
make that decision later and I might
look at it be like oh I look horrible in
that picture I'm not posting that but I
might be like oh that really turned out
well the lighting was really good by
happenstance not because you know saying
oh I got lucky on that one let's put
that on let's put that on the feed
that's all I'm saying I don't because I
am like you I don't want to think about
social media but in terms of them okay
out there do we agree on the length and
the number of photos that you should
take I probably have a higher tolerance
for the amount of photos but and I think
that that's that's just whatever
whatever person's preference is you know
you could probably begin to feel when it
feels you you forget to sense that like
oh I'm taking too many pictures
I don't feel grounded anymore I don't
feel like this is about the camping trip
I don't feel like this is about hanging
out with my
kids I feel like this is yeah
documenting it and I just I'm what I'm
saying is that listen there are people I
mean we haven't even gotten into this
but like there are people who do
lifestyle vlogs and I don't know I mean
either they have Const they developed
the art of being in the moment but also
capturing it that sounds like a
nightmare to me personally but you also
think about you know I follow Jimmy chin
the photographer who follows Alex
Honnold around and I mean this guy is
taking amazing photos that obviously
he's taking time to set up but I don't
get the sense that he's not in the
moment well he's a photographer he's
also a photographer he's capturing the
moment right but and I'm just saying I
just feel like you got to know what your
personal threshold is and if it feels
like you've crossed over into making it
about documentation versus experiment I
mean experience that that's gonna be a
little bit different yeah it also
applies to the people that you're with
right so in for instance if we went
camping together and my frequency of
photo taking was too high for your own
personal comfort then I would probably
have to adjust that yeah well you take
so many damn pictures man if you were to
say that then I would see like I'd be
like all right chief I'll take less so I
just think you had but I feel like back
to the original question
taking your foot taking a disposable
camera if you think that's a fun project
or take your phone but leave it in
airport mode and just you take what you
should have taken one photo or airplanes
like airplane mode I mean neither what
neither one even one photo you know what
give it a shot next time okay I think we
I think we've answered some
no spiders were harmed in the in the
making in this conversation I did kill a
gnat though and I'm not making that up a
very small gnat like bug what we would
have called a gnat in North Carolina
landed on my hand and never seen one in
the air biscuit studios before but I
killed it immediately just wanted you to
know it's on the ground now it's your
wreck is that gonna be spider juice of
what no I don't remember the brand and I
also don't want to endorse it because
you know listen I don't want to endorse
killing spiders I didn't want to
encourage it he's your wreck not killing
the spine no my wreck is a hot sauce
that I found I get well I guess my wife
found it you you know the sweet baby
Ray's who won the best barbecue sauce
taste test on GMA okay we independently
tasted like a bunch of I don't remember
that popular brand photo it was like
bull yeah we took a lie we took 24 per
second actually
but there's bullseye and some other
brands that everybody recognized and
sweet baby Ray's one and I think sweet
baby Ray's won pretty handily and since
then I've actually been sauce I've been
getting that I've been getting that
barbecue sauce and re recognizing how
good it is for just like a cheap bottom
shelf barbecue sauce that company now
has a hot sauce and it is in the
Louisiana Hot Sauce you know like sweet
and not too hot but like really good on
fried chicken and anything like that
like grew the good on eggs like a bright
reddish orange sauce basically Texas
Pete we've been getting Texas Pete made
in winston-salem North Carolina forever
not made in Texas I understand that and
I like that I think you also are a fan
of that hot sauce right because it's got
its there's something about that style
of hot sauce because you can almost
drink it it's not super hot but it just
it goes on a lot of different things
sweet baby Ray's is an upgrade what's it
called hot baby Ray's it's just called
sweet baby Ray's hot sauce I think and
then it I think it says new excuse me
had some before but when you go to a
restaurant in California you usually are
gonna get two different types of hot
sauce you're gonna get Cholula or
Tapatio right those
what that's what it's all these places
and I prefer Cholula over Tapatio
yeah but neither of those really has
that like louisiana-style red thing
happening and I'll check it you gotta
check it out put it up I'm gonna check
it out put it on some eggs that's what
I'm that's that that's what I'm gonna
tell you to do scramble up some eggs
some cheese eggs put a little cheese in
there sometimes I start with an onion
get some onions in there and then throw
a little sweet baby Ray's hot sauce on
it and tell me what you think about it
speaking of that tell us what you think
about this hashtag ear biscuits this
conversation can't continue
wherever hashtags are found and will
speak at you next week to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]